hey guys welcome back to the Spates
Borderland podcast I am stoked to have
Spates on board supporting model ad for
season four and the reason I'm so stoked
is because I do believe it is the best
beer on the market and the only real
decision for me when I do go have a beer
is do I go for the Spates gold medal the
great tasting OG lager or the crisp and
refreshing Summit Ultra with 75 less
carbs always a very tough decision but
the beauty of it is there is no wrong
decision to be made so cheers to our
mates at space for bringing you this
episode good on you mate
[Music]
[Applause]
uh what a ladwell today I'm lucky enough
to be joined by one of my favorite
people to talk to on the planet he's
incredibly intelligent he knows
everything about rugby business and life
in general and he's even released a
children's book which is arguably the
greatest book ever written and today's
coming on to talk about life after rugby
or life post professional sport which I
know so many of you guys will find very
beneficial I know you already know who
it is it is the great lad Tim the legend
Bateman welcome mate oh mate
what's he gonna say mate one of the
worst I reckon that one
yeah standing there but great to have
you on mate um first time I've had a one
of the sponsors products during the
podcast
um space Summit Ultra couldn't choose a
better person to share one with to be
fair yeah cheers mate it's bloody good
to be here have a beer with you yeah and
this sort of came from I guess a couple
of weeks ago when we were both talking
about life post Sport and I guess some
of the challenges that involved with it
and
um some of the stuff you were talking
about and ended up coming up with six I
guess challenges you thought were the
key to overcoming and something that I
thought [__] this is there's some good
stuff in here be cool to be able to
share this with
um the people who are in that position
or coming into that position for that
time I guess yeah mate it's um well I
mean we hear about it a lot a as as
players it's like you know prepare for
Life After rugby and
um so people have you know you hear
about it all the time the challenge is
that people go through when they when
they transition out of the game but I
never really thought about you know what
they actually looked like yeah in detail
you know what are the different areas
that you have to sort of prepare for or
be careful of yeah and so it's actually
cool talking to you about too obviously
we've sort of both finished around the
same sort of time and we're both sort of
you know a year to two and into
retirement now and um and I reckon it
does take you about that time too it's
sort of that I mean a year year and a
half after finishing is when it actually
feels like you have finished you know
like the first six months you're still
watching the game thing like I could
still be out yeah
you retired maybe five years earlier but
you just kept going back to Japan yeah
exactly but I'm not so I mean for me it
was like at what it sort of boiled down
to was like the Ark in these six things
I reckon there's like six like
fundamental things that are challenges
that will come up for every single
player
um and the reason that challenges
because like rugby provides all of those
for you without you even realizing it
also in a nutshell really the six things
uh like your your physical self so
obviously you train you know you're
looking after yourself physically it's
your mental health it's a really it's a
huge amount of support around your
mental health
third round as your as your social
well-being effectively yeah I guess the
ability with the mates every day and all
that sort of stuff
um the fourth one is around finances you
know like that's you looked after
financially really well as a player and
um and you know that that whole piece is
taken care of
um the fifth one is around its structure
you know it's like if you sign a
three-year contract you pretty much know
where you're going to be what you're
going to be eating you know what you're
going to be training like and through
this time which provides like a real
amount of certainty yeah and then the
last one is this that's like that sort
of um like it's like passion or purpose
piece and we can get into each of them
but I think um for me the other six
things that rugby is just being a rugby
player provides you and it's not these
things aren't all unique to rugby but
they're all things I think you have to
think about when you're transitioning
out like how you're going to look after
yourself physically what are you doing
socially what are you doing mentally you
know what what is this thing that you
that you need to satisfy in that passion
or purpose piece because yeah each of
those things when they're not there
that's been I think challenges really
come up how'd you come up with this six
sort of pillars or challenges like what
we're doing to come up with that sort of
list
um I think I mean I think well one thing
I've always been quite um
my brain's probably racing a million
miles an hour and I think um I think
introspective is probably something I've
always been and so it was really just
reflecting a lot on like my own
challenges when I'm finishing so like
the the immediate one for me was
physically you know it was it was like
Shivers I actually have to do something
to look after myself physically it's not
on my schedule it's not on my schedule
you know and there's you know the rest
of the life takes over and all of a
sudden it's like man I'm starting to
blow out here I can see myself going
down a track where all of a sudden you
know and you see that with a lot of guys
you know um it's like having a like
building a physical routine post rugby I
think is so important what are you doing
to look after yourself physically
because that just flows into everything
else like in rugby your training is
as you you look it's just looked after
you turn up and you have to do what the
trainers and the coaches are saying and
that just takes care of all your
physical health
um when you're in the real world and
you're working and your family
commitments and all these things going
on it's like fire where do I build this
in yeah
um so like for me like it's not just the
way it look you look physically either
it's all the hormones and stuff that
locking after yourself physically does
for you you know like you know you've
got all these positive like dopamine you
know and the endorphins you know the
oxytocin of being around guys all the
training and in that environment where
you you feel you're looking good you're
feeling good you're away yeah as soon as
you leave there you know and you're not
looking after yourself physically you
start feeling really crap you know and
so I don't know that was a challenge
that I noticed straight off the bat I
mean I don't know what you did but
you're still looking shredded so what
did you how to do what did you do
physically coming out of the game mate I
I was I did I did nothing and that's
sort of something I look back on
obviously my hip I do retire because of
my hips I couldn't run for
pretty much two years just starting to
get back into it now post footy which I
did miss I miss being able to run around
with the kids in the backyard and that
sort of stuff
um instantly you know everyone tells you
man you're looking skinny like boys 48 I
feel like players either go one one well
the other they either blow out or they
get skinny obviously you're not going to
be training at that same intensity that
you did throughout your career unless
you're right into the gym which I never
really was I know you are the size of
your ass but
um yeah I guess that was probably one of
the biggest things I struggled with
where do I fit that exercise in and how
does it look in my daily routine or
weekly routine like and you see some
guys that do it really well you know and
they've like these guys I know that it's
like all right a year after I finished
playing I'd have to run a marathon you
know and then all of a sudden I've got
something to look forward to that
they're working towards that they build
their routine around or some guys get
into biking or some guys get into but
is a really good one for guys to think
about because the other thing you miss
physically is that sort of
confrontational
combative contact that element you know
like I started you bring it out on the
touch field
[Laughter]
um but um but yes I reckon yeah it
doesn't really matter what it is you
know like some guys are getting to
CrossFit they get into you know um you
know rip like bodybuilding yeah I think
whatever it is like making it a routine
and having some goals around it like
that is what we're used to you know
we're used to that so I just think it's
um if I was a guy coming to the end of
my career
um I'd be thinking all right I'd be
trying to make some plans anticipating
that it's going to be hard and I know
that I'm going to have to get some
structure around how I'm going to look
after myself physically because I swear
if you don't get that piece right
everything's harder and it's not as if
the world ends yeah but I just think if
you're going to make a transition smooth
like nailing that physical piece I think
is is one of the key ones I mean you
look at someone like Richie you know
like he's out there running um 30
endurance races yeah it is and it's like
it's that I think that ticks a few boxes
yeah like this that we'll touch on later
on the sort of passion purpose piece but
um yeah I mean like we all know guys
that have done like really done well
physically after the game and I think um
it's definitely something that everyone
can learn so what about the guys who do
have a career ending injury and a
physical aspect comes really hard
um a lot of guys finish with knees
things like that what what's the what
would you do there well that's what I
reckon once again it's like got to be
planned out yeah you know it's got you
got to think about it and in that final
stages of your career like biking for
example was a lot of a lot of guys go to
with hips and knees and stuff because
it's obviously low impact then
um you can do it for longer periods of
time without damaging the body like
running's broke away like I even for me
running six seven eight K my bodies are
screaming at me my joints
um but also you know like my training at
the moment I'm not going to get any
fitter any faster any stronger
um but I actually try and do all the
different elements that rugby did so you
know on a Monday I do like I actually do
speed and repeated speed oh yeah yeah
true and it's and it sounds a bit silly
but for me it's like if I want to go
play a game of touch you're getting a
basketball I want to be able to run
faster that's pulling your hamstring
over again and calf yeah and it's like
you know I'm used to training like this
I like that sort of training so you have
to have a few broken Broncos
so that's my Monday it's 45 minutes
that's all it takes yeah um Tuesday I do
a full body string session
and that's um once again not putting up
there's certainly no records being
broken anywhere near what I'm doing I'm
thinking this is training for the 50
years that's why I'm approaching this is
like I need to be able to train three
four times a week for the rest of my
life that's the way I was like if I make
it too hard you know then I'm like I
could miss this one yeah I think that's
one of the biggest mistakes a lot of
people make okay they go too hard too
early they set their goals too hard
every day I want to do it yeah and our
gym session there's just nowhere you can
finish it if it's not sustainable here
yep so like make it real easy so yeah so
that's full body weight Wednesday day
off I usually float or sauna ice bath
just a bit of recovery in that day
um Thursday I do like a hit session yeah
um so 44 once again 45 minutes and then
Friday I do a long run and an upward
weight session so once that Pro takes an
hour yeah that's only four hours
training total a week it's at a time
as I mentioned I'm not breaking any
records but I think I can maintain this
for the rest of my life and you know
because the reality is like people who
are physically
healthy when they're older the other
people that have trained three days a
week forever rather than they've smashed
themselves for 12 weeks yeah and um you
know become shredded that's that's not
sustainable so flying something
sustainable I think is crucial too four
hours like it still sounds like a pretty
significant commitment especially for
someone with a schedule you have
obviously
um two kids
um business owner author now
um into rugby coaching again with
Crusaders development so you've got a
bloody busy schedule to prioritize four
hours for exercise there's still you
know a decent commitment it is it is and
I mean for me as well it is like top of
my list though I'm looking after myself
has to be tough in my last yeah and
that's you know this is a learning for
you know for things that I've already
heard previously where
um you know where business will come
first or rugby will come first or even
family I have to put myself first
because if I'm looking out it's the
whole European analogy you know put your
own mask on first before you start
helping anyone else because ultimately
our kids and our wives and stuff always
going to be the most important things to
us but if we're not looking after
ourselves first then how do we expect
about look after anyone else like you
have to be healthy physically mentally
emotionally yourself
um or in your best state to be able to
to give the best of the people around
you so it is hard trying to find four
hours a week but it's like there is
non-negotiable it's locked into my
calendar if there's things that come up
like I'm sorry I can't I can't do that
I'm training at this I don't say I'm
training
I've got speed yeah but
um but it's like locked in my physical
and sort of in recovery sort of mental
side over there so that's like locked in
my calendar like notifications that come
to me to go and do it and um yeah I
think that's the that's crucial to get
right it's a good learning for me
because it's definitely not something
that I've ever prioritized and that's
why I have struggled with that physical
side I'd always put work first I'll put
family first I'll put all my other
commitments first exercise is sort of
the last thing I'll do at the end of the
night if I've got time and yeah and it
does fall into the back burner more
often than not well it's another good
point like it's finding out when you
train good because I would have been
three or four months I was trying to
train like six in the morning and that's
not even that early for some people yeah
but I'm just an absolute nightmare at
six in the morning you know like I just
the quality of my training and they're
just getting myself out to train was
just so hard I was like once again if I
want to have a 50-year approach to this
yeah why am I doing this yeah so I get
up and I work then so I start working
really really yeah and then at around
about sort of eight or nine
um that's when I I like I'm 45 minutes
I'm gone I'm doing some training now
okay and it's um because it's when we're
used to training too for and rugby
obviously that's women would always do
it sometimes like my body's used to it
[Music]
um
yeah and then just figuring out the
eating piece too you know how does that
work you know because you're used to
having this massive portion sizes and
you know having to eat all the time to
bulk I mean we're probably both always
on that bulk diet so trying to you can't
go too long without eating and all these
things now I feel like I don't need to
eat that much yeah yeah and once again
everyone's different like everyone has
everyone's body's different but for me
I've like I feel like I've sort of
figured out what I need to do like I
don't eat now until midday true fasting
yeah and that's society sort of between
12 and eight oh yeah
um and that's an eight hour window it's
not too bad at all I don't even get
hungry in the morning but
um that there helps as well yeah um I
still there's still a good chance I'm
gonna blow out and this is all going to
fall to pieces when this podcast comes
out I'm probably gonna mean it but it's
just an absolute swab but once again
doesn't it no I'm not saying I'm perfect
by any stretch yeah but this is
something that everyone has to think
about I reckon when you're transitioning
right and we're only on physical Day
Spring on the next five what a start
we'll be on so the next one is that
that's the mental side of it I guess
yeah so like you know if you think about
being in a rugby environment you've got
a lot of positive people around you and
everyone's like wanting to be high
performing like you can't underestimate
what that does like it's not that's not
common in every facet of work everywhere
you go and so you've got everyone that's
wanting to be there wanting to
contribute you've got you know say a lot
of positivity a lot of mentors mental
skills coaches and you know like mindset
videos on getting yourself up yeah and
like once again it all just feels normal
in a rugby environment when you get out
and you're like yes your decking
footings or you're out at 7 30 in the
morning after off to work it's like you
know like you know like what are you
doing to make sure you're looking after
that part because obviously that part I
mean [__] physical means all they
sort of they blend together yeah but um
that mental Pace I think a lot of guys
do stroke struggle post footy you know
like mentally
um and so once again it's not one size
fits all but thinking about like how
you're looking after yourself means who
are you hanging out with
you know that's actually lifting you up
or you know pulling you back down what
are you reading what are you listening
to if you're listening to this podcast
you know you're probably in a good space
you're in a great space but you know
like our stricken being being a little
bit proactive around that you know like
thinking about you know someone said to
me once um you know you're the sum of
The Five People You spend most of your
time with you know and that was like a
bit of [__] that's uh and who you
spending most your time with it might
not be physically might be who you're
watching on Instagram what are you
listening to on podcasts that are
effectively the people if you wanted to
see what you're like from someone else's
eyes it's actually if you've some if you
smash those five people that you see
most of your time with together that's
probably who you are all right you know
like and so I reckon that's that's you
know for being careful with that yeah
who are yours
well definitely my wife and daughters
yeah that's sort of I suppose Blends
into one um I've got a couple of like
really good mates from school sort of
five five of us that have kept really
close
um from right back then
um so we've got like a really good crew
to trip away together every year and
stuff it's pretty awesome but I think
once again that the listening and and
reading I heard I do listen to a lot of
stuff and there's a few sort of quite
influential
podcast and stuff I mean this is one of
them the wisdom of this podcast is
incredible but um it's yeah it's I just
think that's something to be conscious
of yeah
when you're when you finish up sure so
the keys to the mental side coming to
the end of your career what what would
you say the keys would be to nail
um
knowing what makes you tick effectively
what gets you up and that's different
for everyone so one of them for me is
I've always been interested in certain
things like the book writing or or
things like meditation and flotation and
well-being like learning about this
stuff it sort of engaged me quite a lot
and so um yeah finding what you're
passionate about what you enjoy doing
and then actually just putting making
sure you're carving out time to do that
stuff you know if you know that it's
important that you're
um you're learning then make time to
learn you know yeah that's an important
part of your um your life mentally as as
being able to sort of manage anger or um
you know like deal with frustration or
you know you're nervous you need to
start pushing yourself outside your
comfort zone by understanding what those
limitations are and actually just trying
to find ways to develop that
I think is um yeah I think that's that's
that's a tough one and others I do think
they blend in with physical yeah nice
okay that's two down four to go
what's the next one well you know we we
talked about this too
um but um you know it's the it's a
social piece of rugby you know like you
turn up to a a rugby environment and
like you've got guys like you know guys
are Richie Monger who's just taking the
piss constantly yeah it's fun you know
you're like there's a lot of banter a
lot of
um you know you're pretty much you know
even if you moved overseas say say you
go to France or you go to England or go
to Japan you're walking into 50 mates
yeah it's really what you're doing you
know like you got 50 mates that you're
gonna be your social stuff's just taking
care of for you isn't it yeah like I'm
sure you you found that too I think it
was I look back on my career and there's
definitely the my favorite part of the
game is all those memories you have
after the games you know traveling
like you say those moments in the sheds
or the banter training the people that
you meet especially when you like you
travel around the world to play you meet
so many cool people that you keep in
touch with and you just have that
connection with
um definitely one of my favorite parts
of the game and when when it's gone I
was fortunate enough to sort of stand
there with the coaching so I still felt
like I had that part of it or at least a
little bit of it in the in the
management circles rather than the
players but talking to different people
and on the podcast as well it's
definitely the one thing people miss the
most is going from having that group of
friendship to then chat now who are my
friends who do I hang out with it's
awkward to message the the players now
because they're all doing their own
things so those those friends are almost
sort of gone unless
um you're really tight with them but a
lot of them will just stay in their
rugby Circle so really important to of
those friends outside of the game that's
so true you're right as well that that
awkward feeling of when you finish
playing you're like oh man I don't know
if I'm you know because even though
you're mate Yeah you sort of all of a
sudden when you're out you're like oh am
I going to be that annoying guy now I'm
like yes but
um but you're so I mean that's me too
like the best times through my whole
career they're all just a funny moments
in rugby they're all the moments that I
remember from the game yeah like
um and there's not many jobs that you
have such like-minded people and and a
group you know like obviously you've all
got some like a one big thing in common
which is Sport but there's a lot of
other things you were really driven
you're all like pretty light-hearted and
wanting to you know have fun and you
know wanting to work hard together
you're all quite similar in a lot of
ways obviously there's big differences
in people in rugby it's not everyone's
the same but
um you have a lot of common ground so
it's quite easy to have like quite deep
connections with people and get fun with
people yeah
um so when that yeah all of a sudden
you're out the other side
unless you've got something once again
unless you've thought about this stuff
you know like it's a challenging one
yeah I mean for me
once again like um I had a couple of
really good mates from school and I was
you know still in contact with a lot and
we'd hang out and stuff together and
that that's important you know so we
have touch games or we'll be you know as
I mentioned earlier go on trips together
every year and stuff and sort of feel
like that I'm I'm in a reasonable spot
there with socially yeah but one I know
a lot of guys that they go out of the
game like [__] like
yeah I'm in this work environment I
don't really like anyone in here yeah
and you know what am I doing you know so
you're literally spending like 10 12
years with this group of guys who you
become really tight with and then
instantly they're not all gone but it
just it just does feel awkward like even
for me like
going into the coaching where I was
still part of the team environment but
then it also becomes a little bit
awkward to message one of the players
like do you want to catch up as a coach
player I don't know if people found that
weird or I was overthinking it but
um it's definitely something that your
conscious of you like [__] is this is
this a bit weird to go to lunch with a
player or what yeah it's funny hey it is
funny like that that social piece and
like it doesn't have to be um it doesn't
have to be anything special but I think
just starting it off somewhere and
that's what that's like Studio that
you're on with like rugby isn't unique
in that that these things are only in
rugby yeah like these a lot of careers
and a lot of jobs where a lot of these
things are locked after for me this is
just that you know it was a way to like
frame up my sort of experiences in it
but like if you if you if a challenging
social connections not just having a job
like that that satisfies a lot you know
that that gives you a bit of structure
which we'll touch on soon you know there
will be people in there that you'll
enjoy spending time with you know like
if you're doing some social sport you
know and you're alongside a few other
people that you're sort of bantering
with and through the week and
um you know some chat groups that you're
sort of you know interacting with so
there's
um it's just I think it's just being
conscious of it it's been conscious that
there will be probably a change socially
when I finish playing and what am I
doing to make sure that I'm I'm not
going to lead it become something
significant you know
um like the physical mental and um
social
um you know they were touching on that I
just think guys should think about this
stuff a little bit it doesn't have to be
some massive big rigid plan I mean I'd
love
that um you know that the NZ RPA sort of
thing that would put some time into this
stuff and like like help guys with that
transition and think about a framework
around that yeah that could look
because I think it could be quite um I
just think it's important yeah so the
key there would probably be I remember
hearing this when I was playing like
making friends outside of the game
things like that I never really took
much notice of that but I guess that's a
big one for when you're coming to that
Endo having these interests outside of
rugby making friendships outside of the
game as well yeah I reckon that's the
two ways to to like think to think about
with this is have friends outside the
game so like don't have all your eggs in
one basket you know like keep in touch
with the Union mates with your
schoolmates with your family like so
that all not all your eggs are in rugby
and then the other one is
might start doing something socially
when you finish play some social sport
you know make connections with work
colleagues with other with other people
try and spread your you know put
yourself outside your comfort zone a
little bit sort of risk a little bit
um because you know like humans that's
what we are we're social we're social
creatures you know it's funny like um
you know the the most punishment that
you can give someone
and in jail is solitary confinement put
them by themselves if you think about
that that is the most that is the
biggest punishment that we other than
buddy some places around the world that
do you know bloody bit of putting a
little bit but effectively it's like
that if you want to really punish
someone you make them lonely yeah and by
themselves and they're in their own head
we need to have connections we have to
have social connections so
um yeah have have mates and do things
outside of the game when you finish
um I think it takes that box oh yeah
good says
three down is it oh yeah sure what are
we down to number four what's this one
financially Finance or you know favorite
with this this um you know that's an
obvious one you know like as rugby
players you know you're paid to do
something that you just love doing and
it's a finite career it's gonna finish I
don't know what the average lifespan of
Ruger player in new zealanders now but
I'm pretty sure it used to be about
three years yeah
um so if if it's the Sun goes to the F1
year two years three you see some guys
are lucky enough to pay longer but
everyone's gonna finish and so you're
gonna have to change career obviously
and that's that that is tough man you
can see in your mid-30s and you go out
and you're starting a square one and a
new career um you know like you're back
to being
um you know you're the you're the boy on
the on the yard or you're the um you
know that you're the Junior and whatever
thing you're doing yeah you've gone from
you're really starting back out where
most people in their mid-30s yeah start
like
almost seniors yeah in their career and
so um yeah that that obviously takes it
to the manner a little bit too but also
in the pocket and you feel that that
you're going to start again somewhere
yeah
um I don't know I don't know what you
did financially through your through
your career to help set yourself up for
post rugby off mate for me that was like
I know a lot of guys sort of spend their
money they spend their paycheck weekly
or monthly whatever it is and they get
to the end and think [__] man what do I
do now I've run out of money the stress
polls on honestly opposite I was really
conscious almost too conscious the other
way that I felt like the only money I
was going to make in my career was
through rugby so I was you know I was
trying to save or invest every sort of
penny that I made and
um I always wanted to have the a
two-year buffer financially so that
there was no pressure on me to jump
straight into the next one because I
didn't know what I was gonna do things
like that and I was I was so stressed
about it that when I got there and I did
find a job the relief I had like that I
was I had an income post footy was was
more than anything that I had in my
career so I was like
I'm at the point now where I am more
comfortable to spend money than I ever
was playing even though I was making way
more when I was playing than I am now
just because I feel like
like you said before about the end of
your career it's always going to come to
an end I feel like I'm in the position
now that I can make money for you know
the rest of my working life so
um the stress of having that ending date
and not knowing when that was was always
something that hung over me so I wanted
to make sure I was financially prepared
for that yeah I mean that's that's an
awesome way to to be obviously you know
like really aware that it's finishing
and so you're preparing yourself for
that I was similar I was probably less
Wise Penny wise you know if that makes
sense so I was like I always spend a lot
of time on investing and you know like
what am I doing with the big stuff in
the big rocks but I wasn't very good
with like just the little like the
dinners or the beers or the you know
just the little things that that money
can just disappear quite quickly in yeah
um so I didn't go and blow you know
thousands of dollars on crazy stuff but
at the same time I probably spent you
know way too much on eating out and way
too much on right out or you know like
just all those little things that when
you're finished you've actually got oh
actually man I need to yeah I can't just
be that he's going out all the time that
money's just disappeared you know so um
I think it's yeah it's going to be
different for everyone you know for some
people they're going to have to adjust
to way less money in that and that are
used to spending a lot for some people
it's like for you like yourself it's
more like actually I can relax a little
bit now because I sort of I've got the
rest of my life to think about this
stuff financially but um yeah so for you
you know how you went to Japan maybe
three or four times was that a big part
of it like financially
um it's another top up I guess yeah
massive like I know for me to look you
know the way that I've the decisions
that we made as a family as well made
had a big impact on the way the
decisions are made around money in rugby
um you know we had kids I had on my
first year of playing rugby
um I was 19
um with the Crusaders I was still
studying full-time and I had Shyla
eldest yeah so I was like you know I
always felt like I'm going to be gone
here soon like they're gonna realize
that this guy [__] let's get him out of
here so it was the worst like foot half
foot out a little bit yeah just thinking
I was thinking about the next thing so
um which definitely I think is not the
best way to be you know if I if I could
go back if I could talk to my younger
self now I'd be like mate just be all
alone you've got to be all on if you're
not all done you're out you know
um once again I'm not disappointed with
it but it was like a bit of fear around
my own ability and and having to look
after Laura and look after the girls and
stuff like that I I was like actually I
need to get this right so definitely
that impacted my decision making around
going to Japan Japan obviously we got
paid a lot better than we were paid in
New Zealand
um but also The Outsiders that you were
to do a lot less yeah definitely yeah
you know a lot more time with the family
we were back then it was 14 games a year
I think that we're playing out here in
five months off
you know that's um when you're looking
at that compared to 11 months and yeah
and yeah intensity area and the salary
you were on was
a World Records
they've never quite recovered from it
I've met a serious dents and Coca-Cola's
profit
no it was it was I mean I I joke but it
was good money for someone at my yeah at
my level you know what I mean and um and
definitely eternally grateful for that
you know and but I mean regardless of
what level are you playing if you're
playing professionally in rugby you're
getting paid well you know
um to do what we love doing and so um
even if you're not investing really well
I think learning about money is
something you can do you know learning
about that you want ultimately you want
money working for you you know that's
the way I've always approached it it's I
want to have for me it's I want to have
freedom of time
freedom of location and freedom of of
financial finances so I want to make
sure that whatever I'm doing like I can
be where I want to be I'm doing what I
want to do and not having to worry too
much about money and so that's that's
generally what I'm doing now I can I can
I know I mean I'm working probably 80
hours a week at the moment so it's not
as if I'm like avoiding work is that
including your four hours training
including yeah let's look man no that's
not but um but um so it's not as if I'm
trying to avoid everything because I
don't like working yeah it's more that I
want to work on the things I want to
work on
and and the things that are enjoyable so
um you can only do that if you've got
yourself in that position financially
and I'm when I'm not in that position
yet but you know we're working towards
that and
um I can honestly say that I'm able to
work on something that I actually love
working on which is which is um
yeah very lucky and that's obviously a
studio and anyone out there listening
could be in the same position really
couldn't they couldn't add to read there
g'day guys Tim Bateman here from o
studio if you're trying to get some more
control over your own time and money and
therefore looking to open your own
business o Studio might just be the
option for you look wellbeing is a 4.1
trillion dollar industry worldwide and
we've found a model that works so the
key for us now is finding the right
people to join the journey if you're
interested fill in your details at
ostudio.co.nz forward slash lad and I'll
get in touch back to the show but it is
like like you say it's a it's a genuine
thing for guys to think about when they
get to the end what what am I going to
do what do I want to start a business do
I want to just work nine to five what
what is life going to be like for me
post 40 and if you are under that
Financial pressure and you've got a
family you need to find a job almost
straight away you're just going to be
falling into something you're not
passionate about and you'll fall into
that trap and then the cycle starts I
guess of all those things you're
speaking about yeah I agree like if you
can do something like what you've done
where you've bought yourself time to
find out what you want to do so you've
bought yourself you're effectively
investing in yourself to give yourself
enough of a buffer of time and head
space to be able to decide actually
conscious decision I'm going to go and
Coach I'm going to do I'm going to do on
podcasting I'm doing this I'm investing
and I think that's that's the ideal
scenario you know
um the reality is I think for most
people is that it's um that you're going
to have to make a decision reasonably
quickly and I actually my thoughts on
that as well I don't think it's a bad
thing I actually don't I sort of see
this a little bit like when you finish
high school and you take a gap year
before you start studying those guys
they genuinely make a better decision
with their study than people that come
straight from school into study the
amount of people I know that have gone
straight from school into into study or
a trade or something because it's this I
have to make a call
um they end up changing their mind and
they've got big student loans and stuff
and they've and if that had been able to
buy themselves time to do it they'd be
better off so I reckon like um
are can treating your first year out of
rugby like a gap year where you're just
taking something yeah it doesn't matter
what it is go work on a work on a bloody
digging footings it doesn't really have
multiple things if possible I think that
would be one thing I'd add is the more
things you can try see what you like see
what you don't like and then sort of
funnel it towards the ultimate thing
that you do want to do yeah I agree it
just it gives you it gives you it gives
you the structure that we'll talk about
soon it gives you a little bit of
financial support so it buys yourself a
little bit of time it gives you some
social stuff just doing something a job
take about having in the back of your
mind that you're still open to what when
you're figuring out what you really want
to do but ideally within the first two
or three years I reckon out of the game
um I reckon you want to have made a
decision of you know I know I love doing
this type of work and I want to work
with these type of people and this is
how I can go about anything maybe you
have to start at the bottom again two or
three years out of the game but
ultimately you know that whole long-term
approach to things you're going to get
way more fulfillment if you're working
on something that you actually enjoy
doing
um you know which is what we're lucky
enough to do on Rugby all the time so I
think trying to find ways to replicate
that and whatever it is is so important
yeah yeah oh they're getting better and
better
someone else
oh yeah good
um number five we're up to are we yes
um so that's structure yeah
um I know this sounds like a bit of a
okay you know structure what's there
that I think um when you have no
structure in your life
I just reckon and these these different
degrees of structure that everyone needs
you know like for me I actually need a
lot of structure so talk about the
training like that has to be like locked
in and if it's not locked in it will
disappear yeah like my family stuff I
have to like lock it in so I literally
in my account you know I see before on
my calendar I'll be one of my training
times my family time is locked in there
as well oh yeah and so it's like this is
what I'm gonna be doing no one can move
this yeah I remember that from the
previous podcast we did when you're on
Covert and you were in isolation and you
had your whole days fully plan like your
seven day covert isolation all planned
out like everything to a t so you do
love structure yeah and I'm I know I'm
OCD like I'm definitely OCD with this
stuff but also like I I have to
structure and like non-structured time
so it's like I know this so like if I
hit I feel like my whole weekend I've
got nothing as long as I know I've got
nothing and I know that I've like I can
actually relax and I don't have to have
know exactly what my working is going to
look like at all it's more just I know
that I'm allowed to not do anything yeah
because yeah it's been it's I don't know
it's that's over the top but it's
honestly the way I am yeah
um so but I just think understanding
what like how everything fits together
and when you're training when you're
looking after your family when are you
catching up with your mates like what
time have you got for work when you're
switching off like that for me was a
real big one like actually having to put
a pen on like this is when I'm stopping
working and then I felt better about
stopping working because it's like it's
in there and that's such a hard one to
it because it works endless and I can
imagine as a business owner and how busy
you are like there's always something to
be doing it's the same in coaching like
you can't really watch enough footage
because there's always something else to
look at and when in to put that down and
say okay I've done enough or I'm not
even concentrating anymore because I'm
I've been going for too long but making
that time like you say to just saying no
okay now let's do something for yourself
put yourself first and you'll be better
for it yeah and it's it's um as soon as
like if you say for someone you headed
some
um presentation that you had to present
to the Crusader group you know like and
they said all right put together a
presentation for the Crusaders on I
don't know on back attack you could go
out and start chipping away at that and
you know it might take you a week to
sort of put together
um might take you two weeks to put
together I don't know but if someone
said you've got to do that and you've
got it by tomorrow
so tomorrow at two o'clock you're
presenting a back attack presentation
you get it done yeah you know and so you
work you work to the times that you you
create for yourself you work to your own
deadline so it's almost like I think if
you box things in it's like all right
this is the time I've dedicated to this
and I'm gonna do it you know it's like
it happens you know what I mean and so I
think um like once again that doesn't
just happen like you're right you could
sit and watch footage for hours it's
like I've got I've got 90 minutes yeah
and I've got it I've got to smash this
yeah and that's all the timer starts
bang yeah and you're on and it's like
you guarantee yeah you'll get it done oh
no doubt and you're less distracted too
obviously so easy to be distracted when
you're doing things like that you know
which are important but you know there's
just sort of extras and you get a
message from someone and you get caught
on your phone for another few minutes
and just the distractions of life you're
starting to talk to someone and things
like that if you've like you say if you
zone right in with the time you've got
to get this done yeah it's so much more
efficient yeah and once again everyone's
different like for me as well like
because I lean towards working you know
like it's easy for my family to miss out
all my training and stuff I'm looking
after myself to miss out so like I know
that I have to structure that stuff in
so I suck it all right I'm switching off
this time because me and Miley are going
to be into this or Laura and I'm going
out for lunch on a Friday you know we're
going to do a date night and that night
and it's like locked and nothing can
move it has happened and that it may
seem it's almost like a little bit cold
you know it's like you shouldn't have to
stretch the time of your family it
should just happen naturally for me it's
like structuring in like the Baseline
that's required
like you can you know I know there'd be
guys and I'll be happy that this that
fault of this myself where you feel like
it's been easy to make even making time
for your wife or what time for your
relationship yeah like we'd all love to
say oh it just all comes naturally and
it's just easy we make the stuff we're
just off the cuff and it just works out
I mean if you can do that amazing yeah
for me it's like all right what isn't it
what happens what do I have to do weekly
for it to be just a baseline you know
like so that when I know that Laura and
I are making time for each other and
making time for the girls anything that
happens above and beyond that it's like
great you know it's like that is where
the spontaneity and stuff comes in as
well yeah so um I think rugby gives us
that structure it's like we know that we
have a Wednesday day off and we know
that we haven't spent time things like
but most people will do something with
their family on Wednesday because it's
just there for you or you know that you
have a Sunday off and say like cool we
can do this or
um you so finite with your structure
already in rugby that you naturally
build that in whereas when you leave for
the game it's it's just so much more
fluidity in life that that structure can
fall off the Wayside really quickly and
you can start leaving your partner by
yourself and your training starts
disappearing your relationship with your
kids sort of go away a little bit and
yeah so I think once again it doesn't
I'm not telling anyone to like say that
they have to do what I do because
everyone is so different but I think
thinking about that stuff is important
it's an interesting way because it's
also something that when I wasn't in the
rugby scene or and coaching yet I
enjoyed not having
you know being able to go to a wedding
or something which is on a weekend you
know when you're a rugby player you've
got no say in when you can go to events
it might be an awesome event down the
road but you've got a game and you when
you don't have that such rigid structure
that you do on a
um rugby career or sporting career
um you've got that opportunity to do
these things again which is something
that I quite enjoyed when I wasn't into
when I had to sort of six month time
frame when I wasn't in coaching all
rugby yeah you're so right you all of a
sudden
um you've got so many more options hey
like there's a concert on sugar I don't
know I mean yeah I don't have a game
yeah yeah I don't have to worry about
drinking beers and yeah
um you know like you've got way more
options when you finish that that rugby
answers them for you it's almost like
the packet of chips you know the ice
cream it's like in rugby makes those
decisions for you yeah yeah yeah you
know you've got skin folds coming up
again but um so like yeah I think yeah
being just around your decision making
and the only way you're going to get
conscious or any decision making is by
having some sort of understanding of
what you want and that for me looks like
structure and so I'm not I know I sound
like overly OCD but I do have a lot of
time like where it's flexible you know
and and
um but my flexible time is
structured free time exactly exactly and
I can enjoy it more you know like it's
like I know I know there's nothing
waiting for anything that comes up so I
know that's that's good let's play
that'll be dealt with yeah because I'm
doing this now yeah you know I like it
yeah good okay and number six final one
oh yeah save the best for last yeah the
best for last um I reckon this one as as
um as underestimated you know if and
it's um so it's passion and purpose yeah
so rugby rugby we have that you know
every week it's almost like you're going
to war you know you're like all right
we're in this we're in this together
we're on this journey we're taking this
team on you got that physical like
combative feel around this like man
we're trying to win this thing you know
and that just gives you a huge amount of
like Ford Focus almost point of
reference at the end of the week that
you're working towards and everything's
geared towards us like purpose
like when that goes
and there's like there is no real like
feels like it's a way less of amount of
a purpose to a week or a purpose to
anything to a season it can feel like
what what am I even doing here yeah what
am I working towards what is this yeah
like with no goals you feel like you're
just sort of in the wind floating along
so once again I reckon it's finding
something doesn't matter what it is like
I've got mates that have gone into
British and Jiu Jitsu and it's like it's
for them it's like they get along and
they know that they're rolling and
they're trying to develop this and it's
like they've got this little thing that
gets them away or adventure racing or it
might be a business or a career that
people are really passionate about that
they know what they're trying to achieve
they've got goals
um that just makes you feel so much more
sit up you know you just it's that's
that's living you know yeah did you find
that and yeah well I found like this
this podcast was my my little thing that
I was really passionate about started
off as I was retiring
um after my surgery and
I was just so focused and I just you
know see the growth and you see it
growing and growing and it was like
became my little passion project and
each week you know trying to get another
guest on and make it better and just
learn and that was the thing that I
think gave me that that passion that you
that you speak about so
um it's so exciting yeah I was like
every time I'd do an episode I'd be
pumped it'd become like my game day you
know I'd get the nerves before it the
butterflies like oh man I hope this goes
well I don't want to stuff it up and
then post it you get that little bit of
a adrenaline where you're like yes that
went quite good or damn it I wish I wish
I did that better and then you sort of
review it after it pretty much became my
my Rugby replacement and
um yeah I felt like that was my thing
that sort of got me through and helped
me help me through that stage as well
it's I mean it's such a good example
because that's a good an example of it
of like there's something that because
like we want excitement in our life you
know like the opposite of boredom is
excitement you know and like that you're
only going to be passionate about
something that you're actually excited
by so finding something that just get
makes you Tech you know for some people
that smash themselves in the gym and
bloody you know for some people's big
adventurers for some people's podcasts
yeah
um they're finding something that you're
like pursuing
um is huge like they they um they did
this this study on that it's called the
Blue zones around the world so that's
the the zones around the world where
people live the longest so it's like
these different hot spots of like their
their life expectancy and health is just
way higher than anything surrounding
them or elsewhere in the country there's
a place in Utah is based in Japan a
place in Italy
um and a few other spots around but it's
like what were the what were the common
threads between these blue zones and
there was a little bit of stuff around
exercise and diet and stuff but one two
of them want two of the real strong ones
were like social connection I've talked
about earlier on so they all had like
really tight social connection and the
other one was a real clear understanding
of their passion and purpose in life and
so like you know there's a reason why a
lot of people pass away soon after
retirement you know that's because you
know it's because all of a sudden it's
like this sort of this direction has
sort of disappeared in their life yeah
and so um it doesn't it doesn't matter
what it is but being passionate about
something and working towards something
has clear health physical mental
benefits
um I mean another good example is like
they've done studies on on like uh
features with PTSD yeah
and a lot of it for a long time they
thought was purely tied to seeing you
know combat you know and so being in
challenging dangerous situations and
obviously there's a there's a huge
element of that for a lot of people but
they also had a huge amount of people
experiencing PTSD type symptoms they
post traumatic stress disorder symptoms
coming back from deployments when they
and they hadn't seen any combat at all
sure and so what they this was a thing I
was reading about but it was um
effectively it's like it's very similar
to rugby you're in this group away
together working on this thing together
you've got this like shared assignment
the shared sort of collective vision and
goal around what you're trying to
achieve and you're helping each other
you're supporting each other through it
and it's like you've you know it's
getting you up every day it's like man
we're up we're doing this we're going to
that and we're looking at this we're
doing that and then when they come home
and they're back in their little
apartments
and I feel like they've lost this sort
of put us like man that's that's when
things like depression and PCC type
symptoms like start kicking in it's
because they've lost this like direction
of where they're going like rugby is
like that yeah rugby is like you're in
there man and we're going we're doing
this we're doing that we're on and then
you get out of it unless you've got
something that fulfills that I think
you've got to you you're setting
yourself up for some extra challenges I
reckon do you know what it was around
that blue zone why was those blue zones
what was there
purpose or passion that you know how did
a whole sort of group have the same so
um so there was there was five things
that they all had in common I'm gonna
forget I'm gonna pick terrible with this
but so it was um so one was low meat
diet
low mates out there was made in Orland
there was alcohol and all of them as
well so yeah instead of having a few
years completely
um one of them was
um like a meditative practice Yeah so
and the Utah was around praying and so
like Brooke is praying like meditation
and praying practicing things like
gratitude and stuff they're quite all
quite similar so like a meditative type
practice was another
um there was no actual training in any
of the groups like physical training but
all of their lifestyles are really
active yeah so they were really
um like they were fishermen who walked
to work or bike to this or they baked
their cakes from scratch or so all their
Lifestyles were quite um active active
Lifestyles but no like smashing
themselves training wise then the fourth
one was that connection I talked about
before so really strong connections like
in Japan they have this cool high Senpai
thing where they were like a year group
as your friend group and they'll be they
would meet each other every week and
they'd just be together they've gone
through life together they've all had
kids they've all supported one another
they're traveling through life connected
and then the fifth one was this passion
and purpose so they're all different the
one in Utah was religion so it was uh
it's a Mormon Community there
and so they've got this sort of like
this vision of them like worshiping you
know and we're we're like we're working
the Earth we're supporting each other
we've got a real Community feel to the
way we approach life
the one in Japan was family a real
family so it was really like the whole
life was dedicated to supporting the
great grandkids and the grandkids and
the multi-generational people families
within households and stuff supporting
one so it's a real like understanding of
family in Italy was sustained
um once again it's not sorry and there
was like work as well so work so like as
I mentioned before fishermen or Bakers
like baking into like really old age but
it's just they love it yeah they get up
and they love their freaking baking you
know or forget their fishing and
providing for their family that's bloody
really old and they're still out there
doing it you know it's um so it doesn't
matter what it is
something yeah right it's fascinating eh
yeah yeah bad time and the other thing
around that um I guess passion and
purpose thing is
is it your status as well obviously when
you're a rugby player especially someone
of your caliber you're recognized um
everywhere and you've got a status as a
rugby player and then you hear from guys
that when they stop playing rugby there
now
they now know him pretty quick and you
know no one I remember Colin Slade
mentioning on his one how quickly people
forget who you are and is someone who
was an all black couple years earlier
and then walked down the street no one
recognizes you anymore no one knows
you're a x40 player so
um that loss of status or that
um status that you have in your rugby
career is that part of the whole purpose
thing as well I think so I think it's a
combination of the sort of mental and
and and passion purpose please I think
you're right like it depends on what way
you look at it but yeah I think that's a
big part of your mental sort of
well-being in the game is that you've
got this this status elsewhere which you
know rightly or wrongly is um as it just
comes with with being a rugby player in
New Zealand and so like I I don't think
there is um
any great answer to this but I think
there's some people that have done this
really well home economist they're
saying to me really really
um this was back in 2012 he was like you
know like Rugby's not who I am it's what
I do that's effectively what it was you
know and um
I just think that's a that's such an
important thing to understand that's so
good like things come like it's things
come and go you know and but you who you
are where stays the same you know so
understanding who you are and not having
your whole identity wrapped up and your
level of success and anything in life as
I think just our fundamental skill set
like that's something that I've
definitely struggled with and it's not
even just from rugby that's like having
to be good at things is something that I
have felt like from from really young
age you know that I've had to perform
either in class or in school or at an on
a rugby field in southern like my
identity being tied to that if I'm not
good at this you know failed in some way
um so I think um yeah the status part of
rugby players is it's probably bigger
for some people than others
um but it's absolutely something you're
going to have to prepare for yeah and I
think the Crux of that is just
understanding deeply that it's not who
you are it's just what you do yeah it's
temporary because you you see the guys
who love the status or they you know
they love the
being recognized and stuff While others
not so much like the Conrad Smith great
example like one of the best centers
ever so humble wouldn't ever use a
status for anything he sort of hated
that about it hey like
um that's like you say such a good man
always had some good advice and I reckon
there's there's two I think there's two
things here as well because I see a lot
of guys they're like big on promoting
their brand and probably I think it's no
problem with that yeah using it while
you've got it yeah you know like but
also I think do it but just know deep
down to that that's not that doesn't
Define you you know like so even even if
you've got a lot of
um like a lot of emphasis around
um you know brand and like really
amplifying then that status that's great
but just always just don't don't don't
buy your own sales pitch though yeah I
mean yeah exactly yeah it always just
brings and I think having kids and doing
humble simple stuff brings you back yeah
it brings you back to actually
I'm not this big big man who's bloody um
yeah above everything yeah I think so
I've got no problem with people that do
that and but I do hope that they are
able to to sort of stick themselves out
of there and be like actually I'm I'm
just this guy here who's bloody working
away doing this thing yeah what are your
thoughts on characters like I know some
people I've heard some people speak
about it becoming
sort of separating their personality to
the character that plays on the field
and does all that social media
that's I I don't know I really don't
know eh I I find that space quite hard
like I've actually only just got
Instagram like I go on Instagram uh it
was like about two months ago yeah and I
thought I stayed away from it for such a
long time
um
just because I didn't really understand
it I guess and I just didn't want to
have another thing that I needed to
think about
um around this book stuff that was sort
of part of it they wanted me to have a
platform that I could just talk about
stuff or do stuff on so it was okay cool
I need to sort of I don't know I find I
do find that quite a interesting one
like you know like I think of people
like even like in the podcast scenario
like Joe Rogan's obviously the biggest
podcaster in the world he's 100 himself
yeah he's just authentic like he's just
he just sits on the podcast and talks
some people like it some people don't
but I think then most people do those
numbers yeah exactly and I think so I
think like if that's in the analogy
where there's a lot of podcasts that are
really curated like the one things I
love about this podcast too it's like
it's really authentic it's just
it's almost you know it's just what you
see is what you get
um if you're able to be really authentic
and not have this this like Persona over
here and
um your real self over here I think
that's ideal so you can always just be
be yourself everywhere but the reality
of the world is that you know sometimes
we do have to promote ourselves and we
have to you know help amplify the brand
and amplify things so I haven't figured
that out I don't know it's interesting
so we did the book you spoke about the
book where did that come into the whole
process and life after 40 a couple of a
couple of great reads written by
yourself sad banana lonely lemon yeah
till they're great oh yeah tell you
um I mean this is I mean I've always
enjoyed like writing and like lyrics of
songs and poems and stuff I've always
always enjoyed up words having kids as
well there's books that I really enjoyed
reading and you know you see the kids
really enjoy it as well so I was always
sort of in the back of my mind but
really what the the Crux of it was it
was a couple of like key messages that I
felt like I'd learned in my from through
my life that I thought were really
important so one of them was you know
one of them just that's right from
stoicism but it's around you can always
control your response so it's like you
have complete control over the way you
react in any situation regardless of
what goes on you've got the control to
to to choose your response that's like
the the message I think is important for
anyone to learn
um and so I wanted to like get that
message into a children's book and so
that was a sad banana and then the
second one second when the lonely lemon
was around like loneliness and um you
know understanding that everyone
experiences
how do you combat loneliness for me it's
the stuff we talked about today it's a
connection you know finding a genuine
connection
so how do you find a junior connection
if you're feeling lonely it's like
putting yourself outside your comfort
zone being brave enough having someone
help you find that but ultimately
finding a connection somewhere so it's
like I like to I liked reading
children's books my kids I liked um
always like writing and then it was like
these are two messages that I feel like
I've learned from and I'd love to to
sort of put them into it it was it was
just it literally was a bit of fun but
it has been quite crazy really just the
response has been pretty awesome so it's
very cool number one bestseller in New
Zealand isn't that not internationally
International interesting there we go
but mate it is it is a bloody good book
like you say there's books right as a
dad who has to read you know two or
three stories every night
um I make that sound like it's not fun
but it is if you get the right books and
there is books at you you know when the
kid brings up to you you're like not
this one again I hate reading this one
it doesn't really even make sense where
is oh the sad banana bring me there
every night it's one of the greatest
like you say it does have a good message
flows off the tongue well good pictures
good storyline oh the kids love it maybe
it was the thing that gave me the
comments gives you some children's books
that I've read along the way I'm like
Jesus I could write a book yeah surely
yeah surely if I'm reading this one then
I could do it I mean there's nothing
special about the books though I have
been a bit of fun
um but as I mentioned it's you know just
give give it a crack it's something I've
always enjoyed doing why not and I think
that's such a key thing as well is give
it a go if it doesn't work out then who
cares eh like and you learn from any
experience you do so like if you're
thinking about doing something give it a
crack and what's the worst that's going
to happen like
especially in that example like you
write a book you release it what's the
word someone's going to say oh that's a
crap book who cares you learned the
whole process of writing a book you put
yourself out there and I've learned
something from it so I think it's it's
an awesome attitude although I mean this
is this is this podcast case in point
you know like what you talked about when
you finished playing oh there's
something I want to give a crack I don't
know how I I saw something once around
how many people start podcasts and
finish yeah do you know what that is I
think that's a massive percentage don't
get past seven episodes because that was
always my first goal was to do seven
episodes and then reassess because I
knew that oh it is it's like 80 90
percent wouldn't even get past seven
episodes so that was the always the
first goal for me and then I don't know
I think this might be 190 or something
yeah he says hey what a what a guess
that is but it is the number one sports
podcast New Zealand isn't it
um if if your book's number one in the
world I think this is okay
got it yeah that's I mean it's such a
good example of it like who cares hey
yeah give it a crack just give it a
crack and you like these very very few
times that I've ever regretted doing
something in my life I think I remember
you saying like last time there's
nothing in your life that you regret
like zero things yeah this and that's
genuinely yeah I've made I've made
mistakes don't get me wrong I've blown
stuff out of
poor Investments I've done stupid you
know behavioral stuff but ultimately
like anything that's gone wrong I
definitely have it's like there's
something I've done better because of
their learning as well
so I just freaking I don't know we all
live on me included I'm in my comfort
zone too often like I'm definitely at my
best and I'm like pushing my comfort
zone and releasing some children's books
was definitely me and the girls My Girls
when they they saw that that was done
because that I actually they were a part
of the process too like I'd seen my I
was on lockdown in Japan Japan and I'd
seen Malia are a couple of things like
what do you think about this what do you
think about that and that was quite a
fun process then when it was like okay
these are going to be published and
they're out they were just like dead
it's a social this is social suicide
seriously you're done you are done
people are going to be like what are you
doing so that's sort of but you know I
don't know it's cool for them to see
that you can do different stuff too yeah
and it's just a bit of fun and I think
it's yeah it's quite cool have you got
more on the cards yes two more two more
two more I'm doing at the moment so are
you writing them at the moment yeah
awesome yeah any teasers what are we so
one sort of the six steps yeah the 60s
the mistakes after rugby
um so the sad banana and the only lemon
the first two yeah the next two is the
angry Apple oh yeah and the worried
watermelon oh true yeah so like it's
sort of like sadness loneliness
um anger and anxiety
those sort of big ones yeah so they're
happening at the moment oh they aren't
coming along that fast honestly
how long would it take how long would a
book take to write the first ones in
Japan the sad banana it probably took me
two weeks of like an hour and a half a
day yeah so I had I did that structure
actually yeah I had an hour and a half I
put the timer and I have to sit there
sometimes with nothing yeah yeah and I
left it but I have to stop so that got
probably 90 of the book done and then it
was um the end of my thing was like I'm
gonna send this out yeah I'm like
finished and then they came back to me
and said they were Keen to publish it
and it was like back and forth of
tweaking a few things yeah
actually turning it into something that
was readable yeah right yeah good and
then um so but then the lonely limit I
was back in New Zealand busy so that
took me a couple of months and it was
just like so hard trying to find the
time now these two far out that's so
hard just to hit being in the right
headspace to do that yeah that's
probably the hardest thing in my life at
the moment is like jumping from one like
come completely different situation to
the next situation they're like
completely different
it's like talking serious sort of
business investment stuff and then all
of a sudden I'm thinking about writing a
book and at rugby doing something yeah
then trying with clients or yeah it's
just very I find I find that quite hard
trying to get the right in the right
head space true yeah that's interesting
eh juggling that all yeah there's
certainly a lot of mistakes a lot of
mistakes going on but it's um it's good
fun yeah mate how good what an episode I
know your alarm's about to go off soon
because
um you've got your Sprint set four
o'clock or something so we'd better wrap
that up but man that was I knew that was
going to be a good episode and uh
definitely delivered um when we
mentioned it a few weeks ago like I
thought [__] there's definitely
something in there and that's so cool to
be able to sort of share what you went
through and what you found and then be
able to express that to anyone going
through Post 40 or coming up to it
things to be aware of even young kids to
start thinking about even if it's in the
back of your mind and like we've heard
so many times your career can finish
pretty quickly or at any time really so
the more you can think about the stuff
or start implementing it the better so I
really appreciate you coming on and
sharing some of your good stuff no I
appreciate I do appreciate the
opportunity to talk about it because I
do think that it is important like I
actually do like at um I know we've
laughed and joked a lot about it today
but the reality is that when when you
finish it's hard there's no getting away
from that and it's there's different
levels of hard but hopefully that that
gives a bit of a structure as to as
types of things that can become hard
um and there is no one way to one way of
working you know it's about yeah just as
you've said just now thinking about each
of those things and how what that might
look like in your life
um so that it's not as hard as it needs
to be you know it'll still be hard but
it's at least you're prepared for it or
anticipating what those things might
look like as it comes through
I hate how good I appreciate it
appreciate you coming on and like I said
at the start you're one of the smartest
men I know you're the Jordan B Peterson
of New Zealand really for me so it's
anytime I get to catch up with you um
always an honor awesome thanks for
having me brother you're a lad hey guys
thanks for listening and if you've got
this far I'm guessing you enjoyed the
episode so if you did please give it a
share if you can and also cheers to our
mates at space we're sponsoring this
episode
[Music]
absolutely
[Applause]
[Music]